[Music]
making shop is about redesigning the way
we produce
the way we retail to allow the last
small production
to be in the shop environment so we
won't have to produce
until there is a demand for it
community design is actually ironically
something not very new
back in the 70s and 80s actually we
called it kampung spirit which is
largely basically communities themselves
were
responding to whatever issues they had
maybe the way that singapore developed
became more structural
communities no longer learned how to
respond by themselves they'll be working
with healthcare institutions to see
whether or not
communities have their own responses to
their own healthcare challenges
the local tree project was started to
reduce waste and bring value to the
community
we want to eradicate the throwaway
culture that we have and produce
furniture
and objects that people feel proud to
have
our project is about reducing single use
plastic weights from food packaging
mainly deliveries and takeaways
and we focus on hawker centers where a
majority of our population eats
[Music]
the ongoing r d at the moment is focused
on finding out
how we can strengthen and stabilize this
timber by using sustainable energy
mediums
as this research is heavy on data and
scientific tests
we gained many beneficial numbers along
the way
the project we think was really quite
challenging because we need to speak to
different citizens we may not have
personal relationships with
we've had 119 interviews so far i would
say out of those 190 we've got maybe 30
to 40 really solid interviews where
people are willing to speak
we conducted behavioral research to
understand
how we can make these containers better
for the eating experience
and we also had a number of in-depth
interview with the consumers as well as
hawkers
[Music]
the good design research sponsorship
from design singapore council
was really phenomenal in helping us
begin to just get a kickstart
it has allowed us also to move on to
building up a strong prototype really to
actually pass over to
to real stakeholders as an established
brand
we struggle to find time to work on our
innovation
good design research initiative allows
us to take time off
and to work towards our innovation
our ideas and we must keep innovating in
order to move forward
the good design research initiative has
strengthened our position
this helps improve and differentiate us
allowing us to add value to our products
and customers
[Music]
we hope to achieve a very polished
experience to our customers where they
can come
and see their products being done in a
magical way
we hope to partner with nea to implement
in hawker centers we want to
see these ideas being rolled out and
making positive change
the hope is really to bring it to other
precincts within the country to look at
other kinds of problems
it may not be health it could be mental
health it could be basically youth
delinquency
we're planning to continue working on
research and development for our local
trees
finding other methods to salvage parts
of the trees
or buying products they are normally
thrown away hopefully
we can create a positive domino effect
that drives our sunset industry towards
a more circular future
[Music]